when the Sun sets over melo's bangle is
van batteries takes to the sea his
friend- shows ninos is preparing the
boat a large gas lantern dangles from
the front it doesn't serve any
navigational purpose but is a hunting
tool and it's not the only thing the to
pensioners need for their nocturnal John
set see they say the sea has to be
completely still no wind whatsoever and
the sky must be dark and completely
devoid of moonlight the two of them
glide into the darkness they are known
locally as Pierrot funny or light
fishermen and they're among the few
people on the Greek cyclades islands who
practice this traditional fishing method
besides their lamp they use an eight
pronged skewer and they need keen eyes
in shallow waters they quickly find what
they're looking for the hunt is underway
to fish at once means the night has got
off to a good start the creatures are
paralyzed by the bright light but the
hunters still have to act quickly
finding the fish in the first place is
the hard part and requires great
patience
Oh
if you like you to find the food from
the pillow funny you have to stay out
all night similar Lords discuses opener
crisis means this is no longer just
hobby fishing yellow means of feeding
the family fish should become expensive
I'll in a drop of joy is so if we can
catch three kilos of fish ourselves
that's a big help Tapia district wash in
Apulia cleva yet strict EU regulations
designed to counter the effects of
overfishing in the Mediterranean mean
hobby fishermen like Vangeli are no
longer allowed to legally fish from a
boat the right is reserved for
professionals such as his friend- sauce
both men oppose the Brussels ruling mr.
La Paz gonna give me a son of course
we'd stop light fishing if we had the
feeling that it was bad for the
environment but you saw for yourself
that we are not destroying anything we
only ever catch adult fish never the
young ones like big trawlers do in the
winter months the island of Melos is a
sleepy place the 5,000 inhabitants seem
to hibernate until the tourist season
kicks off in April fishing has lost its
importance for locals but the mayor
doesn't want to let go of the tradition
he considers light fishing an important
part of the Aegean culture
the problem we are doing everything but
can to ensure that pure funny fishing
can be continued and we are talking to
the responsible authorities in Brussels
the gamma 0 very well it is part of our
way of life the sea keeps us balanced
out there on the water we forget the
worries of the daily grind Bob imaginext
a casual observer limited Samaras at his
Taverner captain Nicholas only serves
fish he catches himself he prepares it
himself too and is one of the few locals
who are critical of light fishing he
prefers to use nets I've tried light
fishing but I don't like it it's an
unequal fight I don't see what's so
exciting about it it's like killing a
sleeping animal Nicholas herbs fresh
calamari and grilled bream he has been
catching and selling fish for 40 years
although they use different fishing
techniques he and vamp Ataris agree that
in a few years time the only fish that
will be eaten on me lows will have been
caught by Big trawlers mr. Hoshi in
nearly I only five percent of our
fishermen are left here what did the
young ones are afraid to get into a boat
they prefer to spend their nights in
front of a computer hobby fishing has no
future here yeah Leah the next morning
Nino's sharpens his fishing spear the
weather conditions are forecast to
remain favorable tonight so with no wind
and no moonlight he will be back out at
sea practicing the old Peter funny
tradition as one of the last light
fishers of Melos
you